- One of the more thought
provoking aspects
of Rudloe Manor is this claim
that it's sort of the British
equivalent of Area 51.
NARRATOR: Interestingly,
this would not
be the last time
allegations surfaced
that a crashed UFO
had been retrieved
and taken to Rudloe Manor.
Another much more notorious
incident occurred in the 1970s
and was witnessed by
an entire village.
Llandrillo, Wales,
January 23rd, 1974,
late in the evening,
this quiet rural village
in the Berwyn
Mountains is rocked
by an enormous explosion.
14-year-old Huw Lloyd is in
his home watching television,
when he feels the impact
and then receives call
after call from his neighbors.
Most claiming to have
seen an incredibly bright
light falling from
the sky and then
glowing on the mountainside.
Today, Huw Lloyd still
works on his father's
ranch in Llandrillo.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS: Are you Huw?
HUW LLOYD: Yeah.
Ancient astronaut
theorist Giorgio Tsoukalos
and Nick Pope, a former UFO
investigator for the British
Ministry of defense, met up
with Huw to get his take on what
really happened that night.
Can you tell us
your experience?
Your neighbors called
you to ask if you're OK.
So they pretty much had
similar experiences.
So you're not the only one.
And you were 14?
How did your parents react?
And what time of
evening was this?
So you know, some people
have suggested that, well, it
was nothing else
but an earthquake,
which I don't
subscribe to this idea.
But have you had any
earthquakes around here?
But you saw that light
and it was much, much
brighter than people lamping.
I mean, it was something
almost blinding?
Wow.